[Music]
it started as a legend one of the
greatest of all thousand years who've
kept it hidden to protect Earth from
what was destined to arrive Optimus
Prime you destroyed your home you seek
Redemption
i gue
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard stay with me
boy in a band especially a drummer
these are troubled times without leaders
chaos reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way now the
greatest mission of them all to turn the
tide of human history
[Applause]
[Music]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
my nose seems lost a few brave souls
[Music]
and save everything we've ever known
the operations over we're not giving up
a crime okay
mistake
and I want ice it
[Music]
for my world to live
yours must die
[Music]
y'all want to see some their robots I
supposed to be here
we're kids man we get away with anything
I was just a normal kid before my world
fell apart
look at me why Tom Kennedy's been to
Normal School lived a normal life
some kids used to tease me Wow who is he
far as you're concerned my boyfriend how
long's that thing - uh-huh
[Music]
they'd say you run like a girl
you're gonna take care y'all promise
just don't expect Denny's bedtime
stories you throw like a girl
fight like a girl
[Music]
you out of your mind you're not going
anywhere with me I'll just stay and I
want to fight them I think you're badass
huh
is this okay to be a kid little JLo
funny what you can do when all you have
left it pens on it done quite like a
girl yeah I felt like your girl coming
with me or what
don't you
[Music]
go home is he
turn around what are you getting your
mouth dropped occlusive right now come
on man be careful you get back in your
hole think about what you sick
all right
I can is pointing right at us what
[Music]
but most are heart attack
relax recovered
Wow
whoa
all right toldja covered it is being
said
through the ages without sacrifice
there could be no victory to species at
war one flesh one metal Optimus Prime
has left us 100 billion trillion planets
in the cosmos
[Music]
you want to know don't you today why
they keep coming here
[Music]
on a stay and I want to fight them
now two worlds colliding
the operations over we're not giving up
okay
twenty-one survives
oh my god
forgive me
[Music]
[Music]
you want to know don't you why they keep
coming here to earth where are the
others
once you're hiding I don't sell out
friends
[Music]
you weld is dying not to miss Prime
[Music]
the secret EPS
my makers IEQ
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm really glad I got in that color with
you all cameras
iMacs and transformers partnership
started ten years ago with the first
transformers and the partnership has
gotten more traction throughout each one
time X gives me the tools to give you
the best cinema experience in the world
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build IMAX
Michael's pushed us to be more nimble
therefore smaller but not to compromise
resolution he's pushed us for the 3d to
be more seamless he's constantly trying
to surge the filmmaking experience
give me greedy here
on this movie transformers last night we
are shooting with IMAX 3d and the
results are phenomenal Michael is the
very first filmmaker to take two of
these cameras and configure them on a 3d
rig and shoot in 3d in real time and
that's not trivial the resolution the
detail the clarity it really is
mind-boggling we are using all the IMAX
technology to give you the best
experience you will see this year
hey I'm Michael Bay and I'm a strong
believer in protecting the sentiment
experience this is my edit room here in
my house in Miami I love cutting here
because it's quiet this whole system
types to Santa Monica where I have five
editors Joe Oh No bye
anyway those are my editors I can
connect it with like different room they
can see what I do on my system here and
we can share screens it's a great way to
work a movie like transformers needs to
be seen using the very finest tools the
best sound technology best projection
technology and cameras I'm here to keep
three-d alive and the only way to make
it the best experience for you is to
shoot it natively that means two cameras
two eyes and see exactly what you're
seeing we're the first movie to ever
shoot IMAX 3d we placed these two
gigantic cameras on top of each other to
give you amazing resolution just like
your eyes you see depth and it's
beautiful and it's something you cannot
fake we're gonna spend the extra 10 to
15 million dollars and we're gonna do it
right we're in fact the only movie this
summer that was shot in native 3d so an
image like this the post convert is
virtually impossible see those billions
of little particles here they have to
capture each one of those and put them a
different space whereas when you shoot
it natively it's already doing that for
you
the scale of a Transformers movie is
meant to be seen with big screen
with great Dolby Atmos sound and
brightly lit 3d screens Michael is
always on the cutting edge of technology
for the audience to have them have a
more visceral experience is filmmaking
is a very three-dimensional style
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build IMAX Michael
is the very first filmmaker to take two
of these cameras and configure them on a
3d rig and shoot in 3d in real time and
that's not trivial the resolution the
detail the clarity
it really is mind-boggling
it was a lot of fun to shoot I keep
saying this is my last one and I'm going
out with a bang this is a big scale
movie
action
come on frat I saw Freya in an article
and a papers calling it britain's
loneliest dog she has lived in a shelter
her entire life six years no one wanted
her 18,000 people actually saw her
didn't take her I was looking for a dog
it wasn't decided to take her on by
which time Michael Bay had shown
interest in her action and I said first
of all we give her part transformers now
she is working with Sir Anthony Hopkins
her very first movie and she's done a
great job
good good good he's such a good actor
changing so we never dreamt of having
such a role in the film
and he's a great animal lover and that
said my house off to him for giving her
this chance so rat day how's the dog
good yes great that's phrase Diane
amazing this right here oh look oh this
way right right yeah baby
yeah B yeah I've rescued so many and
they do love you more man's best friends
we're a team